patience so this is gonna be a sort of
follow-up to the talk I gave yesterday
so let's say I define realistic
polynomials and so today is sort of that
the probabilistic analogue of this of
this polynomial we see that they have a
lot of nice properties in in probability
theory so just to remind you of what we
talked about yesterday we said that a
polynomial P is real stable if it has no
roots in the upper half complex plane we
talked about many closure properties of
this real estate polynomials for example
if you plug in a real number or a
complex number with not the non-negative
imaginary value the resulting polynomial
remains stable if you do partial
differentiation it remains stable and so
on okay so now okay let me start talking
about probability so so let's say let's
say mu is a probability distribution so
for most of the talk I assume I have a
set of n elements from 1 to n I'm
looking at subsets of this set so so mu
is basically a distribution on subsets
of the numbers from 1 to n now is
important definition all the generating
polynomial of MU
define as follows you you take you right
down the expected value of okay let me
you look at before let me call it G Musa
Jimmy the generating polynomial of mu on
variables V 1 up to the N equal to the
expectation of Z to dance okay so let me
rewrite it so this is basically the
summation of overall sets which are
subsets of numbers from 1 to n the
probability of of s under mu times e to
death again to put it differently this
is just summation over all sets S which
are subsets of 1 to N mu of s times the
product of the i4i this is called the
generating polynomial of mill let me do
an example so let's say let's say you
have two Bernoulli random variables b1
and b2 let's say b1 has prior P 1 and B
2 as prior P P 2 now I want to write
down so these are independent I want to
write down the generating polynomial of
this distribution so it's probability P
1 times P 2 they both come up head so
I'm going to get Z 1 Z 2 then we
probability P 1 times 1 minus P 2 I get
only the first one it probably T as I
could have given this probability P 2
times 1 minus P 1 I only have the second
month so I get Z 2 and then you
probability 1 minus P 1 times 1 minus P
2 I have nothing that's a generating
polynomial you can rewrite this
polynomial differently as follows you
can write it as it's really P 1 times Z
1 plus 1 minus P 1 times P 2 times Z 2
plus 1 minus P 2
now you see each of these polynomial is
real stable and I have product of two
little polynomials and generating
polynomial of this independent Bernoulli
random variables is a real polynomial
this is the strongly distribution so
this is due to Porsha so many of these
stuffs statements about this you know
distributions come from from from this
paper so we same you with a strongly
already saw that two independent
Bernoulli so in fact any independent
Bernoulli give you a strong binary
distributions so I want to now give more
examples and then I'll talk about you
know closure properties and many other
properties of these distributions
so so let's start so the next example
one random spanning-tree distributions
I'll get to that like in 20 minutes okay
so so what's a spanning tree
distribution so let's say you have a
graph G I want to I want to look at the
uniform distribution over all spanning
trees of this graph so the generating
polynomial is it just is basically let's
say you have like M edges e1 up to en
the polynomial is just summation over
all spanning trees t ZT now I claim that
for every graph G this polynomial is a
real estate polynomial so the
corresponding distribution is strong
right now how to prove it it's again by
like Kushi Binet so and mother of all
estate polynomials so here's the proof
so okay so let me say that that G mu is
real stable is that if I look at this
polynomial determinant of 1 1 transpose
over n plus summation over all edges e
ze L of e what is L of e L of e is the
laplacian of the edge e so this is the
matrix where which is 1 1 at the
endpoints like if edge is UV so it's 1 1
at the u U and V V entry and minus 1 at
the UV and vu n XI 0 everywhere else so
this is the laplacian of the edge so so
this matrix le is the rank one matrix
it's PSD so on and this polynomial again
from this model of our still polynomial
theorem we know that
this is a real state polynomial so this
is real stable and I claim that this is
exactly the generating polynomial of all
the spanning trees in the ground if that
is true then this is this is a strong
rally distribution so how to prove that
that's basically what you do is that you
do the you do the cushy beanie you use
the cui should be a theorem again so so
here I have rank one rank one matrices
remember question DNA says that when you
have this you're looking at determinant
of sum of rank one matrices you can
write it as you can choose every n of
them look at the determinant of that and
then sum it over so I look at all over
all so it's s of n of these rank one
matrices an internment of that there is
one one technical thing which is that
all of these laplacian matrices are
orthogonal to all ones so if I choose my
n my whole set s from here I get zero so
I have to choose this 1 1 transpose and
n minus 1 of these guys so that these
only give me their non-negative no sorry
not nonzero terms so I'm gonna have
summation over all sets let's say T of
size and minus 1 of edges you tell me
Nanta it's always have to have 1 1
transpose or 1 1 transpose plus
summation of ze l e4e now again similar
to you know what
mikheil has been doing a lot so this is
determinant is a linear function in the
ze so we can factor out the Z East
basically I can send this out this is
really Z to the T so now the question is
what is this determinant and that's
something you can you can do you can
just calculate and the thing is these
matrices are orthogonal to the 1 1
transpose this gives you I ghen value of
1 these the laplacian matrix is of the
edges you can see basically with so this
would be equal to
zero if T is not a tree why because if T
is not a tree because it has n minus 1
edges it must have a cycle and you can
see if you have a cycle the summation of
the laplacian like the laplacian of the
edges are linearly dependent so you get
a 0 determinant and otherwise you get
one it so I know and ok this this is not
all I mean we can do the calculation
it's not hard to see anyway so what
you're going to get is that this is
exactly equal to this part
so this is example two now I want it or
example like this to maybe the one was
renewal is not let me say example tree
so it's called determinant all point
processes so so how are they defined
let's say you have a we have a PSD
matrix so given a PSD matrix let's call
it K n by n matrix or a define a
distribution so I choose a set as the
probability of a set s is proportional
probability of s is proportional to the
determinant of K of s comma s so so what
is K of s comma s so if this is K this
is s this is s comma s it's simply there
the rows and columns the sub matrix you
get by rows and columns indexed in s
okay so so what's the determinant I
point process its it says that like you
have this kernel matrix you look at
every set s you look at the
corresponding you know sub matrix the
probability of that is proportional to
to to this determinant of this and the
point is because the matrix is PSD these
determinants are non-negative so this is
a well-defined probability distribution
yeah there's no more I think Austin
which is summation of all of these
things
now okay now there are two questions I
wanna answer first
you can ask who cares like why is this
interesting and because the second one
is that is to see that this is a strong
value as well okay so let me first say
who cares for now it can be anything but
yeah there's a I'll talk about a special
case that you fix the size of nice lady
okay so okay so who cares let me say
there's an equivalent definition of this
if you have a PSD kernel k you can write
it as V V transpose because it's just to
the control SK decomposition where V is
this matrix of V 1 up to me so the K is
really the grand matrix of these of
these vectors now basically pictorially
you can think about your vectors this
way maybe this is one and so on
now what this determinant is is that
like the the probability of one and two
is really this thing you look at this
parallel pipe you get by by by looking
at V 1 and V 2 and you look at the
volume squared of this of this parallel
that's exactly that's that determinant I
wrote there so it's a volume squared of
the parallelepiped of that you get from
V 1 and V 2 for example is equal to
determinant of the matrix the ground
matrix of a V 1 and V 2 the matrix which
has which has entry V 1 V 2 the 2 by 2
matrix the IJ entry is just the dot
products and more generally like if you
have K vectors the volume scored is
exactly the time unit ft scale by K
matrix again K my getting your product
matrix ok ok so that's another way to
look at it now what does it say who
about who cares so the thing is now
suppose you are in like in some
practical setting these vectors
represent some duck
humans like feature vectors of documents
webpages and so on and what you're
interested in is that you want to choose
a set of let's say there is a you know
web search like a query web search for
some query you want to return relevant
results but you want to diversify the
set of return the answers and like one
way to do that is to maximize the
determinant and the reason is that when
you know maximize and termina you try to
choose set of vectors that not only have
large norms but also they are like have
large angles with each other okay so
that's that's the point of looking at a
determinant so so in practice we use
this use to maximize the whole
literature on this there is like a lot
of people in machine learning are using
these things there there's a very
beautiful survey by by kalasa and tasks
are on like applications and the theory
of these the terminal point processes
one thing I want to say is that they are
actually a special case of this strong
granny distribution so that VPP is
strong Riley so how do you prove that
again you use the the mother of all the
stable polynomial theorem so you
basically write this this thing you
write down determinant of I plus
summation of VI VI VI transfer so again
this is a this is a real estate
polynomial because this is symmetric
these are ranked MO and PST matrices
when you open this up again you have to
use Kushi Binet this is this part this
time it's a little bit more involved
cushy Binet but basically you know when
you open this up it turns out that now
again you have to choose n vectors but I
haven't said how you decomposed I there
are many ways of the composer that the
right way to think about it is that you
choose any subset of these vectors which
are linearly independent and sort of
complete it by adding vectors from I
which are orthogonal to the vectors
you've chosen so far so so this thing is
exactly equal to summation over all sets
s subset of 1 to N of determinant of ok
so it's not really determinant so let me
say what it is so this is determinant
they all sets okay so it's determinant s
so so okay so what I mean by this
notation it means that you don't so
these vectors I have here let's say I
have K vectors here and K is less than n
then this determinant of this is 0 but
you don't compute the determinant you
actually this object means that you
compute the summation of the determinant
of all principle minor all K by K
principle minors of this matrix ok so
that's exactly what Kushi meaning tell
you another way to think about this
object is that this is also equal to
this is also equal to determinant of the
the grand matrix of V I V J's for I am
jealous you have to also multiply by so
so you can you can then factor out the
eyes outside of it so that all it took
we should be enabling on here but okay I
don't want to go on exactly so this is
the case case coefficient of the
Elementary of density of the
characteristic polynomial of this matrix
yeah that's true so you can actually
compute compute these things just by
looking at the characteristic polynomial
of the matrix okay so so so the thing is
okay so the thing is if you do that I
could ship in a you exactly get this
this this volume squared after parallel
pipe times e to this so so this
polynomial is also a real estate
polynomial and that's exactly generating
polynomial of the determinant on point
passes yes
no you don't multiply and choose can you
look at all K by K miners and you sum
them up but but each time it will appear
from different set of vectors so if you
if I fix K vectors an aligner it will
appear only once
does that two Bs remembers the subject
right other the gadgets the same to the
s remembers the subject remember Z to
the S yes Z to the F remembers the
subsets yes so don't get confused with
the fact that I'm I'm I'm counting and
minor multiple times because I'm
counting in the respective different set
of vectors so so if you look at a minor
it has contributions from all K topples
of the vectors and each K Topo is being
counted for its particular monomials e
to the S so so it's true I will count a
minor and choose K times but there
corresponds to different monomials of my
polynomial so that's not an issue okay
so okay so now we saw so for three
examples of this strong distribution
independent Bernoulli random spanning
streams and DVP s in fact you can can
even see random spanning trees as a
special case of DPP's so now let me tell
you about closure properties
[Applause]
so
so so let's start with some simple one
let's say you have a let's say me with a
strong writing let's start with this
I claim there new condition on one
complement so by this I mean that
conditioning on one not to be in my
sample either stand on a distribution
again okay so this means that for every
set s this is equal to zero if one is in
s and it is basically proportional to U
of S otherwise basically throw away
every set that doesn't can that that
that do contain one and you renormalize
and under sets that do not contain one
okay so can you prove that this is
stronger you do the substitute zero zero
exactly
so you just substitute by G of me or
zero comma Z two you just basically
throw away everything it doesn't contain
one you need to do any normalization but
it doesn't change the real stability so
another thing you like new condition on
what now you condition an element want
to be in you throw away everything that
that do not contain what about this one
yeah you just look at it's basically Z 1
times partial Z 1 of G mu
and can do more interesting operation
called projection so let's say suppose
she's a subset of and I want a project
and T so what does that what that means
is I want to I mean think about spanning
trees for example you want to project
your spanning tree on to cut let's say
you want to take the intersection of a
random spanning tree with a cut so in
general it means that so let's say I'm
going to use this notation projection
onto T so it's like if I look at me off
projects down to T the probability of a
set s this is equal to summation of view
of s prime where s prime intersection T
is equal to s so look at all of the sets
whose when you whose intersection which
is exactly equal to s and that's going
to be the probability the new
probability of myself okay I wanna say
projection preserve that thing so you
have a map your projection is called
push forward of the man right that
terminology okay anyway so can you see
that this preserving stability or strong
Grady
the variables and equally one not to be
in t to be one yeah so instead G mu of
for every you said VI to be one for all
I'm adding T let me say lemma a
consequence of these three facts for
every for every strand right in
distribution mu and any set say S subset
of n so let's say T subset of n if I
look at it that the distribution of
intersection T for T samples from you
example say random spanning tree you
look at the intersection of T with my
set s this is distributed as sum of
independent Bernoulli it is exactly that
theorem yon mentioned in his talk now I
want to prove it okay so this is not
only true for all ran for an aspiring
distribution but it's also true for all
strong value distribution okay so let me
prove it
any question
your question let me prove it so again
the proof is very quick so first of all
I project my distribution mu onto the
set s so think of s for example as a cut
so you project your random spanning tree
to a cut so this is a strong Riley so
let's say let let me write down the
generating polynomial of this let's say
the generating polynomial of G of M you
project it to s is let's say it has
variable may be Z 1 up to VK okay okay
some number it must be less than or
equal to size of s okay it would be
basically yeah it will be equal to size
of s basically have one variables for
every for every element in the set so
let's say this is the generating
polynomial of the projected distribution
then what I do is that I do
symmetrization I'm going to have the
same variable for everything for all of
this so so this polynomial is real
stable now this other polynomial of
projectiles that you put T for
everything this is also real stable if
you're closed on there if I see matrix
if I substitute for z2 z1
I still have real polynomial so this is
also real stable but now this is a
univariate polynomial it's real stable
so it must be real routine now I have a
real loot at polynomials with
non-negative coefficient so I can use
the theorem you mentioned yesterday that
any real with a polynomial with
non-negative coefficient can be written
as sum of independent Bernoulli random
items so in particular if I look at this
polynomial this is equal to summation of
a K T to the K where H a is the
probability that that s intersection T
over K
this is the probability intersection T
is equal to n so I have this polynomial
the health coefficient is the
probability that I have L samples on my
on my cart or in my projected
distribution and I'm saying that I can
write this as sum of independent bit so
there's all sorts of nice properties out
of this you get that not only that you
get concentration you get that this
distribution has satisfied you an
identity it's law concave it's unimodal
and many other things so for 30 minutes
in you still was an explanation of the
name really yeah that would be the next
thing
okay good so okay so now I want to tell
you about another properties of this
strong rally distribution called
negative correlation but before that I
need to say a theorem of Brandon so it's
a characterization of polynomials prove
the following a polynomial P stable inj
partial i of p x for all x
okay so that's that's a set of
inequality so it's okay first of all you
may be multi affine means that your
polynomial is a square free but this
says that there is there are these basic
n square tests to check if a multi
affine polynomial is real stable we just
need to check if these polynomial
equations are satisfied for every X in R
to the N so okay so let me let me give
an example to so so I want to say that
this special case of this implies
so-called negative correlation property
for for real simple no absolutely
electronics no for all X that painted
testing two things
so okay so so let me let me let so let P
be G mu or a for this trip for a strong
value distribution mu and let X be the
on one's vector so so what is G mu of
all ones
it's just summation of mu 2 mu of s
right and that's equal to 1 what is
partial I of G mu 1 it's basically equal
to all set s such that I is in s Z to
the s over the I because I I when I
differentiate V I will go away so see
really this you valid it on one so this
is equal to probability of R similarly
partial J of G mu 1 is equal to partial
to select the probability of J and
partial a partial j-jimmy and one is the
total probability of G so so what do I
get I do
probably that if you sample a set from
the distribution it contains the element
are so so this is also called marginal
probability of the element R and I will
talk more about it
so what okay so now plug this in into
that into that inequality okay let me
actually I can plug it in here I get
that probability of I times probability
of J is bigger than or equal to
probability of I comma J or to put it
differently probability of I is bigger
than or equal to the probability of I
conditioned on J meaning that if I
condition on J to be in my sample this
can only send down the probability of
the problem probability of I so we
already know new for example random
Spinetta distributions they are
negatively correlated from like from
from kirchhoff's formula like 100 years
ago but this actually says that this
this thing holds for any realistic or
not for any stronger distribution now
now so now what I proved so far or
several I discussed so far is when you
plug in x equals 1 now you can ask what
happens if I plug in other values of X
you can actually plug in X to be
non-negative and that act that kind of
gives you this for a conditional
distribution so so it says that not only
your original distribution is negatively
correlated if you condition an element
to be in or out still it is negatively
correlated but so so that is called
dryly so there are major it's called
dryly matrix which satisfies this
inequality only for non non negative
axis and the whole point of this sort of
worship randomly get result is that you
can actually now define a generalization
they call it a strong right that they
not only satisfy this for non-negative
vectors they satisfy this for every like
real vector and now not only you cannot
get a correlation you get many other
properties that you wouldn't have
summarize so for poor Riley wait roids
you have that you have that partial I of
P and X partial J of P and X bigger than
reco to partial a partial of x times P
of X and this is basically equivalent to
negative correlation as under ization
the conditional negative correlation now
we have we have stronger property that
this holds for every X in the real in R
to the N and that's that's why we get a
lot of other property is there some
interpretation like negative correlation
for negative x that's a good question
that's like one of the things actually
it would be interesting to figure out
the probably stick a statement of as you
can yeah that's actually out I don't
know yes exactly yeah so this this
statement says that the off diagonal
entries of the Hessian of log P or
negative so let me also state that say
that so so negative correlation means
that if you look at the Hessian of log P
so this is this is a matrix this is an N
by n matrix you can even you can
evaluate it you can look at the I J
entry and then evaluate it at the on one
vector that's the same as the market as
a statement
so you think so if the Hessian is
exactly the IJ entry of the Hessian is
exactly this that the left-hand side -
the hands
yeah no right hand side - the left hand
side it's the right hand side - the left
hand side so so this says that basically
at every X if you evaluate this at every
X the off-diagonal entries of the
Hessian would be of the Hessian of the
log would be non negative not non
positive so this is this is not exactly
sure you need to divide by the square
yeah sorry I need to divide by Pisco
you're right I need to divide by yeah
okay this is I think it's better to say
it Paul once let's say for one yeah you
need to divide by a genius kiss the yoga
knows also find on the positive order in
the homogeneous case you're going to be
because there's a genius case you've
awoken KVJ yes and I mean you will have
you have a lot concavity no matter what
like if it is very stable you have lock
in cavity but not not your la concave
everyone positive or negative
you don't even guarantee the depositor
okay I thought you get if it is he does
non-negative coefficients I think you
get yeah that's what I'm saying I'm talk
about distributions yes the non-negative
coefficients your lot concave everywhere
on the positive worth even if you're not
how much so but if you look on keep
every rhythm that you're gonna lose so
far if you are because then that is the
intersection of my discussion that if
you subscribe that it's like - station
that is them yeah that's what I'm saying
I'm saying the often ions is a negative
yeah or non positive
yeah that's what I'm saying yeah yeah I
was just yeah actually you're right if
it is not negative oh yeah all right
okay so good so if yeah if if P is if P
is a distribution if you have G of MU
repeated distribution the coefficients
are non-negative then this is true for
all X all of diagonal entries for I not
equal to J is less than or equal to zero
so actually to point out later talks and
email we'll talk about lock concave
distribution and lock and key
polynomials and there instead of this
condition you will have the condition
that this matrix the Hessian matrix of
the log is negative semi definite so
it's a spectral property as opposed to a
coordinate property for this matrix okay
so I said that okay let me say the next
thing that is that there's a different
thing that instead of asking this matrix
to have non-negative non positive
off diagonal entries you ask that this
Hessian matrix to be negative semi
definite and this is called sanema we'll
talk about it is that called la concave
polynomials a la concave distribution or
a strongly lock concave let's see more
about it then even in the BQ this is
called we call it we call this spectral
negative correlation now I want to say
okay so I said negative correlation now
I wanna say the next thing which is the
truncation and homogenization it's
another operation such that these
polynomials are closed down there so
homogenization so this is again a
theorem due to portion Brandon and
Liggett so let's say okay first let me
define it
so say again you have a polynomial P the
homogenization of P P of H is defined as
this it's a polynomial on the CPS on
variables even up to the end the
homogenization of period is defined one
more variable we add one more variable
to make it homogeneous and this is
defined as P of V 1 over V of n plus 1
all the way to the n plus 1 and you
multiply it by V of n plus 1 to the D
max by D max I mean the maximum degree
of all monomials of P so this is max
degree monomial so for example if P is
equal to 1 minus Z 1 plus Z 1 squared
minus Z 1 Z 3 Z 4 plus 2 v 1 then this
this is this has degree degree 3 so I
need to add a new variable Z Z 6 and
then I'm my new polynomial P of H would
be z 6 to the cube plus Z 6 squared
minus
I can say the students they say that he
is real stable and non-negative
coefficients and P of H is real state so
you need an extra you need an extra
condition you need a polynomial to have
non-negative coefficients and this is a
necessary condition if you don't have
that this is not necessarily true so for
example if you look at one minus X this
is a real estate polynomial but when you
homogenize it you get Y minus X which is
not real stable but but if all the
coefficients are non-negative polynomial
remains real stable I'm not going to
prove this I just want to use it
I want to say another operation another
close and operation of these strong
light instruments so it's called
truncation again let me let me be a
distribution and to be between zero and
n the truncation of people called Mew K
is mu conditioned on sets of size K it's
mu conditioned on you basically throw
away every set which varied sizes not
equal to K and then you renormalize
that's called a truncation and okay now
you can use this to prove that if mu
strongly then for okay
how to prove this you basically again
need to use the closure properties of
real estate polynomials so mu is
strongly G mu is real stable now I can
homogenize it so G mu of H is really
stable remember that because I have a
distribution the coefficients of G mu
are non-negative so I can apply this
theorem and the homogeneous polynomial
is still real stable now I want it now
now this is a polynomial in n plus 1
variables I want to only keep the
monomials which have degree change in
the original and variables so I'm going
to throw everything else so what I do is
that I take the N minus K partial of the
n plus 1 of the new variable value at Zn
plus 1 this is similar to exercise we
did yesterday like you have a polynomial
you want to just keep the monomials that
have degree and n minus K in Zn plus 1
in other words the degree in the rest of
the variable is sorry this is not fact
this should be B minus K if the original
polynomial has to be max sorry the worst
polymer has degree D max I want to keep
only the terms that have degree D max
minus K in the new variable in other
words in the original polynomial the
monomials which have degree K so I take
D max minus K partial derivative
allottee that's 0 I only keep monomials
of degree K and this is exactly give me
simple consequence is that you can
define there are this question of what
happens if you restrict or you condition
your DPP to half size exactly K this is
called KD BP repeals are DPP's where you
condition the size to be exactly equal
to ki and you get that k DPP's are a
strong right so for example they are
negatively correlated i've actually a
non trivial fact like I was reading I
was reading some of these surveys and
these the terminal point processes and
it seems that they expect these KD VP
distributions to be positively
correlated because when you condition
the size to be K it seems you are sort
of enforcing like some positive
correlation because it's some it's like
saying if this guy should be in you know
there should be some other correlation
it is you know other elements but
opposite of what the of the instinct
it's actually negatively correlated
another example is you have independent
Bernoulli random variables and you
condition K of them to the sample again
it's a strong guy even though it's not
independent anymore just less room for
everybody else yeah but this operation
is the main thing which is responsible
for wonder what are like in accordance
the truncation
okay good so I have like I started there
2011 20 let me okay
let me uh let me say one last thing and
then we go for the break so this is a
topic which seems very off from strong
value distributions but actually it's a
it has had a lot of applications when
you you know combine this technique with
the techniques you know with this theory
of strong value distributions so let me
briefly talk about it
so okay so before getting to this I need
to define one more I need to define two
things first
Newton polytope so what is a Newton
polytope it's basically the convex hull
of the indicator vectors of the support
of Istanbul a distribution so it's the
convex hull all 1s s where s is in the
support of meal
that's called the Newton polytope so one
example is the spanning tree polytope
choose you choose a random spanning tree
distribution you look at the indicator
vector of all spanning trees and that
you know that would give you a book on
the convex hull of them and would give
you a Newton part of that polynomial or
oh okay so that's one definition so one
more definition
so so let's say let's say I have a
vector lambda in an n-dimensional vector
that is non-negative if P is a strong
line P of Z 1 up to Z and strongly then
P of lambda 1 z 1 up to lambda and the N
if you scale Z I by lambda I as long as
all lambdas are non-negative this
remains a strong righty that's again
simple to see from from the closure
properties of a strong male distribution
sorry I'm a tree unstable and a lot for
poor for distribution is that if mu is a
strong Riley then let's call this lambda
star mu this is the polynomial the
generating polynomial is just you know
lambda 1 z 1 of 2 lambda ends here this
polynomial is strong radius
so so stronger distributions are closed
under external pins so is the real
straight polynomials
I want to stay so let let P be a point
in the in the Newton polytope of your of
the of the of your strong distribution
so that P the interior mutant poly tope
then the entire means that's not on the
faces there exists lambda there exists
the external field lambda such that
marginals up lambda star mu is equal to
P so what does that mean that means that
all I the probability of I in the
distribution lambda star mu is equal to
PR
why is that interesting that's now you
start from some distribution it has some
marginal probabilities but you may be
interested in some other distribution
with some other marginal probabilities
this says that as long as you're you
know targets margin marginal
probabilities is inside the Newton
polytope you can perturb the
distribution by by applying an external
field to get to any point of your
interest and still you will still you
will have a strong value distribution
and furthermore you can compute I'll
talk about yeah yeah you can actually
see this in many ways they're like a lot
of pay a lot of papers who study
variants of this in very very different
languages so I guess you can see that
Scoob it says as a scaling you can see
it has maximum tropi distributions you
can see this
[Applause]
so let me okay let me okay let me
briefly say how you prove this and then
we can go for the break
[Music]
so actually multiple ways to prove it
one way is to prove it by max entropy
distribution but there's a dual proof by
scaling which which is I think quicker
and maybe nicer so so you look at the
following polynomial you look at you
minimize log of G mu V 1 up to the N
over over Zevon to the P 1 all the way
to the N to the P and this is the
infimum is over all these which are
non-negative I claim that the optimum
that if you if you optimize this you
plug in lambda for the optimum Z that
exactly gives you the right the right
external field so so first why can you
solve this so how to solve again it's
just the convex programming so basically
you do a change of variables you
substitute e to the Y I for Zi this is
similar to the convex program I talked
about yesterday
for for approximating the per minute
except you didn't have the PI's in the
denominator so you substitute here then
then basically you just have log of G mu
of e to the Y 1 up to e to the Y n minus
summation of zi for in order to solve
this you just need to GM you to have
non-negative coefficients as long as
Jimmy will have not negative
coefficients you can do this
optimization this is a convex function
and this is again lock sum X his convex
as long as yeah this actually convex
like so Mexican X so so in fact you can
solve this optimization problem as long
as you can we can evaluate your
polynomial so it
for a strong line you can evaluate these
polynomials there are other examples
like la concave polynomials that you can
also evaluate this we can solve analog
of that for example now one last line of
it you said for strong Rayleigh you can
evaluate it if you plug in for Z 1 up to
the end you want to see this can have
exponentially many term right you want
to evaluate the polynomial given to you
them oh let's say let's say you can you
know the coefficient of each monomial or
I call yeah that's what I mean all right
I'm glad you can't have exponentially
many coefficients an algorithm that if
it is a strong Riley and you only know
the coefficients and then what I call
them you can evaluate this I'll talk
about the algorithm look briefly in the
discussion section but it's a Markov
chain algorithm it's not it's not
trivial statement ok now how do you
prove this basically just write down the
optimality condition here so so you just
differentiate this with respect to the I
you get that partial I know that partial
VI of this log of G mu over vivan to the
p1 all the way to the end to the PN
should be 0 now you to the
differentiation so it's the same thing
it's basically partial VI of log of G mu
must be equal to P I like partial zi of
P I times log of V I so you do the
differentiation this is this is really
partial zi of G mu over Jamil must be
equal to P I over the I just doing the
derivative of the log and so this is
we run into this and this is a cool and
this is equivalent to that VI times
partial Z I of G mu over G mu is equal
to PR and what is this the numerator is
exactly generating polynomial of all you
know subsets that contain element I this
is the generate form of everything so
this is exactly the marginal probability
of I it has to be equal to BI this is
not the proof because you you need to
prove yourself you miss the thing this
is the main thing okay but yeah III this
is okay this is the main I guess many
people this is the man it's not a big
deal but this is in although scaling
goes out you might think is I agree I
agree there a technical part yeah there
there are technical parts you need to
say it in film is attained and so on but
yeah the upshot is that this is actually
what you want that that's why that's why
you want to do it this way because
because this exactly certify that the
marginals are equal to
so any question so by the way so it's
not measurable change right that's why
you need to be inside the interior of
the polytope in the interior yeah I
think if you're either outside
okay okay there's some technical if
you're outside of the polytope then it's
not a pain at all if you're on the
polytope then some lambdas can become
infinity but if you're in the polytope
it's always a team and if you're even if
you're if you're not in the interior on
the boundary you can find a sequence of
these polynomials that converge to your
thing so you can so yeah okay no
question maybe let's resume at 12:30 for
like 10 minutes
[Applause]